this video is just gonna be me talking
about my thoughts on indie game stuff
and in general how the kind of
independent games community has changed
over the last 10 20 years or so and how
I feel that's kind of affected me as a
game developing me as a programmer or a
software engineer kind of working in
that industry in the games industry as a
whole
and just kind of me talking about really
my thoughts so that's what this video is
gonna be about she's gonna be my opinion
doesn't necessarily mean that this is
how it is this is just how its kind of
affected my life and how I think that
I've even changed because the problem
with talking about topics like this is
that a lot of it happens to be kind of
dependent on on the person talking about
it as a human being as a person we all
change
we all grow our interests change over
time for example I can't just I can't
just say that the games industry has
disintegrated and disappeared and it's
now a boring place to work in compared
to four years ago because that might
actually just be me as a person having
changed over four years and becomes
someone who is no longer interested in
making games so all I'm saying is that
at least these vlogs these videos that
I'm making I don't want you to to
necessarily think that this is I'm
stating facts just because I work in the
industry therefore I know everything
that's not true at all it's just kind of
me sharing my life with you guys in my
opinion on certain things and what I
love
actually do is read your comments I love
to hear from you guys as to how you feel
because although I do kind of network
with people in the industry quite a lot
because I I work in the industry
obviously so I talk to people but I just
love hearing what people both outside
the industry and in the industry and the
greater industry kind of have to say as
well so leave a comment below in regards
to anything I say don't necessarily feel
like you have to start hating me because
you disagree with me let's just talk
about it and we can kind of just start a
discussion because that's what I kind of
love to do with these videos anyway I
don't necessarily want to drag this
video out and to just talking about the
whole my whole opinion of the indie game
deaf community and how that's changed
and how game development itself has
changed over the last ten to twenty
years
I might make follow-up videos or videos
in the future that might talk about that
I just wanted to say a few words
I guess specifically on how I feel that
things have changed and what I feel that
kind of area of the industry isn't the
first thing I really want to say is that
I feel that game development has kind of
split up into two distinct parts it was
always kind of two distinct parts but I
feel like as time goes on they become
more more separate and that is kind of
the triple a game deaf community and
then the indie game deaf community or I
mean Chevrolet is such a term that I
guess the corporate kind of commercial
games versus the kind of independent
games independent itself usually means
free of kind of any publisher or that
son as well myself free from kind of and
any publisher although as we know a lot
of games that we consider indie games do
in fact have a publisher so really indie
game dev I think is just more of a genre
now than anything else and it's commonly
associated with kind of teams of people
that make games
that unnecessarily to lodge right it
might just be like two or three people
or maybe a small team of ten people to
kind of fund it themselves through
either kind of crowdsourcing like
Kickstarter or patreon or maybe they've
just saved up money and they've kind of
just go on indeed that way hopefully you
can hear me all right
it's gonna Indy in the sense that
they've left corporate jobs to found
something by themselves and that that's
kind of another I guess definitely
independent games but really I'm just
talking about kind of change the small
people work on games versus kind of
commercial or corporate games my bike
just fell over that doesn't win great go
ahead Michael house is did break I won't
be right back
no luckily that they didn't because I've
broken these glasses before well this is
a different pair same glasses but anyway
the point is songs coming out the point
is when I talk about independent games
I'm talking about games that are made by
independent team spending like a small
team of people who aren't funded by a
massive organization whereas commercial
kind of it Triple A games I guess it's
just a larger group of people usually
usually corporate and commercial enough
where they have investors and they have
people to please and therefore as you
probably all know the common kind of
Association of evilness comes from
because their motives are Conner percent
pure in the sense that they're not just
aiming to make a good game for people to
play they are aiming to make money and I
think that's a really important
distinction between kind of commercial
or table games and indie games we're
indie games might be I mean obviously
everyone wants to make money but they
might be more leaning towards creating a
good player experience because that is
more important to them to make money in
the long run because they can capture
people's attention capture it over metal
I kind of build an audience and then
monetize that further out or kind of
triple-a companies who already have a
large audience and therefore I feel they
don't necessarily have the players best
intentions in mind because they're not
trying to make a game that it's going to
be as good to play as it is just to make
more money because that's kind of what
the commercial world is about and the
business world is about so to kind of
distinct groups of over two kind of
distinct distinct groups of people
creating products that are seemingly the
same but are yet different and I just
want to kind of I guess this video is
almost gonna be opening a dialogue as to
how I feel about that and there'll be
plenty of videos I think for going on
because it's already been like probably
over five minutes and I haven't actually
said anything I've just been kind of
finding terms and stuff like that
that's kind of how I see the community
and what's interesting is that as the
years go on it seems to it seems to
change in the sense that it seems to
grow further further apart people tend
to maybe start realizing that commercial
studios are aiming to make money which
is I don't know like to me that's I
don't know how they didn't say that
before I mean you know at the
entertainment industry the games
industry they make products which are
the games which they are all services
which they then sell to make money and
the whole point of that entire industry
is to generate money that's kind of the
point of pretty much any business out
there so I'm not sure why that's kind of
new to people but I think maybe because
players that were once young and maybe
growing up and becoming a little bit
more
I don't know smarter I guess or
something like that I'm not really 100%
sure but either way it kind of just
tends to become more about the
commercial money-making aspects than it
is about creating art or creating kind
of player experiences which is what the
indie kind of game dev Crabbe seems to
think that they're more about so that's
kind of my thoughts I guess on the on
the disc on the difference between the
two groups of people that tend to I
guess make games triple-a commercial and
then the kind of indie game tech game
dev teams who are completely different I
think that a big reason why it's changed
so much is because the scale of games in
general has grown enormously I mean if
you think of games in the 90s there
rather small groups of people working on
them maybe like ten people and they
create you know what we kind of consider
triple against because they were made by
kind of huge companies or companies that
are huge now and that was kind of as
much effort I guess as people were
willing to dedicate to creating video
games but if you look at games now I
mean they had the same like the the
biggest games out there have similar
budgets to movies like we're talking you
know over a hundred million dollars to
make one product to make one game
whereas you know if you look at the 90s
or early 2000s like it wasn't like that
at all games were kind of a lot smaller
and scale people weren't trying to
create such massive games and I think
that because because I guess business
men or women business people have kind
of decided that games are actually a
decent investment they kind of see games
as almost a waiter I can pull more money
into a game and get more money out of it
and they kind of end up scaling up their
investments and you get live studios and
you get massive kind of hundred million
dollar games and obviously independent
game teams can't compete with that kind
of money that kind of power so they end
up making completely different products
and that separation starts to kind of
exist and grow I think so that's
definitely interesting that's not to say
that independent game development is all
about the product and not about money I
mean if you think about how many people
have tried to recreate something like
Minecraft to make money like people
people do that you can't you can't
generalize triple-a game dev as being
like evil an indie game dev as being
amazing because
it's completely different and there are
so many independent game teams that just
stop existing after a while just
completely fall apart because their
games don't sell well and obviously they
need money to keep running because
people need to they need to pay salaries
to people they need to rent an office
space all that kind of stuff
there's costs associated with game
programming and game create creating
games basically so of course there's
gonna there's gonna have to be some kind
of revenue flowing in in order to pay
for those expenses and making games does
tend to be fairly expensive which is why
I guess a lot of game dev jobs are
associated with low salaries and kind of
not making much money because games tend
to be more F more effort than they're
worth usually of course some games like
Minecraft explode exponentially but for
the most part games aren't really seen
as a very smart investment that there
are risky investment even now in 2018
where games are doing fairly well and we
are becoming quite a large chunk of the
entertainment industry it's still not
something that I think you know would be
a very wise investment for example if
you were to say to a group of people hey
leave your jobs let's make a indie game
dev studio will make a lot of money
that's risky I mean yes you might but
you're probably not going to a store a
risky kind of investment for indie game
dev people so of course money is still a
big issue for that I just think in
general
commercial kind of companies money that
they just potentially tend to be better
at making money than indie game deaf
people and better at conveying that
perhaps like better better at kind of
better extracting money from players and
because of that they're seen as being
more evil whereas I don't think that's
necessarily true because I think that
anyone who makes a game would like to
make money I mean if money if anything
guarantees that you can keep making
games in the future so of course at the
end of the day everyone's goal kind of
is to make money unless you're just
making a free game that's like just
either bet for education for teaching
yourself how to make games or for
learning how to make games or you're
actually trying to all you're actually
trying to kind of learn how to make
games or just make something fun in your
spare time like of course not everything
has to be about money but in general I
think the industries are of course
trying to make money so that's kind of
the money issue I think aside I also
think that while people tend to divide
those two industries they they really
should have I mean the only difference
is the amount of people working on the
game like if you look at large studios
apart from just a number of people
working on the game I think the history
of the studio meaning all the technology
the studio has built up is also quite a
large an asset that smaller companies
just don't have if you were to create a
completely new company from scratch with
maybe about five to ten people right now
and your goal was to make games as an
example you wouldn't have really any
base technology to start with which is
why you probably
the game mentions that this unity are
unreal because you wouldn't be able to
like you could create your own game
engine of course but that would just be
thought should that be such an expense
that people thank you so much time is
unto effort it is easy to start with an
existing product like unity or unreal it
is still G game on that versus a kind of
commercial studio who has been around
for 10 years they already have built
their based technology and they would
obviously be more inclined to use that
so apart from differences in people it
also the differences and kind of
technology and the assets and the power
I guess of the reach that those
well-established companies do have but
at the end of the day really you're both
just making a game you're both just
making an interactive experience per
player so maybe it's not so smart to
start kind of completely separating them
yes they are different but I think that
we've got to blend them out to be a lot
more different then they kind of off so
yeah and even to the point where people
start talking about how do I get a job
in the games industry oh well do you
want to work in a triple-a studio if you
want to work in an indie game that's to
you that's that's how deeper I think
it's become where the skill set required
to work on independent games is so
different than the skill set required to
work on commercial games that to me they
kind of feel like two different
industries so yeah anyway that's how I
feel about kind of a state of indie
games I want to talk about some other
stuff such as what it's kind of like to
get a job in the commercial game
industry versus indie game industry what
I think are some good tips for
transitioning between the two industries
as well as how like how I think unity
and unreal have really changed the indie
game dev industry and an impact the
entire game dev industry and in my
opinion they've kind of made a lot of
things
as well sir yeah thanks they're kind of
the kind of made a lot of things worse
as well so definitely ideas for future
videos but anyway hope you guys enjoyed
this video let me know what your
thoughts thoughts are in the comment
section below I'll try and reply to some
of your comments as well and maybe even
make videos out of them to talk about
them I'm still here in Germany
definitely follow me on Instagram to
keep up to date with what I'm doing the
Cherno is my name on Instagram and I'll
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]